>>"Hey, is this the place where you
can get a job to make people sick?"
And the guy's like, "Yeah."
>>Students in Scott Comstock's
Scientific Communications class are
critiquing the product of their
semester-long exploration of the role
of bacteria in the health of soil.
>>Okay, now I want feedback.
>>I like how you asked for
a job to make people sick,
because you wouldn't
like normally think that.
>>But since the bacteria
does that, it makes sense.
>>Each student produced a unique
"Soil Superhero Pamphlet,"
which integrated science,
art, history, math,
language arts, and multi-media.
A team of seventh grade teachers
at King Middle School began planning
the project during a three-day
summer session.
>>At the beginning of every
expedition, we usually look
at District Calendar to see what
we're going to be doing for the fall.
Then we start zooming in a little
bit on exactly what it looks
like from September
through say, December.
And we X-out some days
we wouldn't be here.
And then we kind of, what I like
to call, maybe bracket the time
of a kick-off, through
the culminating event,
and the celebration
of the final product.
>>This is where we start as a staff
is creating the model before we ask
the kids to do it.
So essentially we kind of run ahead
seven to nine weeks in advance
and figure out what exactly
we're going to build.
So here's a good example
of an informational
pamphlet around bacteria.
There's like a science
piece around metabolism,
and that's a science content piece.
Here's a math piece around
size of their bacteria.
This is a multi-media piece where
the kids have drawn their work,
characters, text and background.
And then they would scan it and
then they would bring that in.
So we did that first
to see how challenging
that would be for the kids.
>>Do we have some flexibility...
>>The scientists were all -- they
were like, "Oh, sure, we'll come.
So they're all very
excited to do this."
>>In Expeditionary Learning we
love to develop relationships
between the students and community
members, because the excitement
that it generates in the
students, deepens their learning,
and lengthens their retention.
>>There's a word that
you might not know.
The word is "soluble."
In other words, it's able
to be dissolved by water.
>>Gail: Ruth contacted me and
says, "I want to do this thing
with the kids about soil bacteria,
but I don't a lot about
microbiology."
So we sat down over the summer,
and we probably talked
seven or eight hours.
And she read microbiology textbooks,
and she did a lot of
learning on her part.
>>One of our ideas was to create
a comic to kind of jazz up
and make bacteria colorful
and exciting for the kids.
But to also teach them the benefits
of bacteria in soil scientifically.
And so we brought in an
expert, who showed them how
to make something come alive
through illustrating it.
>>Today, we're working with Annie
O'Brien, a comic book artist.
And she's teaching us
how to make expressions.
>>It can be a line.
>>And we learned how to draw
some eyes and some mouths,
so we can make good
facial expressions.
>>And they would start storyboarding
out different ideas to start coming
up with this little story
about habitat and setting.
So we're taking the content,
making it exciting for the kids,
and having them make a mini-product
like in a comic-like
situation on their laptops.
If they're creating a
character for the comic life,
they'll do something like this.
They'll black-line it.
they'll color it.
They'll scan it.
And then we'll pop it over here
into a folder called "Drawings."
And then, here's their character,
and here's their situation.
They can go over that
on the District server,
bring it back to their work
space on their desktops
and start to manipulate that.
As we get so much digital
information in the computer,
we have to start organizing.
So typically, we'd have something
like this that we'd create,
where we'd have a major folder, and
we'd have Social Studies, Science,
Math folders in that, which would
house the Social Studies information,
the Science information.
So when it was time to create the
product, we knew exactly where to go.
>>Do you guys know how to get
to the King Middle website?
>>It doesn't work well when you ask
kids to learn new technical skills
at the same time you're
asking them to master content.
So what we do is we scaffold
it so that we're asking them
to learn a new set of
technical skills around content
that isn't hard for them.
We might ask them to produce
an organizational structure
around shooting letters of
the alphabet in the building.
It's content they already understand.
Scott asked them to learn the file
structure that they're going to use
in their final product for their
expedition, well in advance
of ever thinking about how bacteria
and pamphlets are going
to be put together.
So it's a matter of being smart
about how you plan your teaching,
scaffolding, collaborating
with your team members,
and giving kids the confidence
to build meaningful
products around deep content.
>>And when I ask the other students
to move out, you're going to slide
into their spot, open up and show
the scientists your particular piece
that you're working on improving.
>>Narrator: During the
Learning Expedition,
students present their work and
get feedback from outside experts.
>>Okay, a de-nitrifier is a superstar
when bacteria collect organic
nitrogen formed in the biosphere.
That's correct.
And then it breaks the
compound down to decompose it.
I like how you're breaking
the sentences up
and making it really
easy to understand.
>>As part of a culminating event,
students distribute their pamphlets
to local garden centers,
universities,
and at the main Flower Show.
>>There's assessment embedded in
everything that we do all along.
But that final product is out there,
and it's going to be celebrated
and it's going shared
with the community.
And it's exciting.
You know, we get to
hold the kids to that.
We get to hold ourselves to that.
And someone said once, "If it's
worth doing, it's worth doing well."
And that's kind of our
thoughts around that.
>>Grammar, spelling, punctuation.
We'll just think about those things.
And thank you very much, Kaeleigh.
[applause]
>>For more information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org